[Music]
mrs. Ganton booty in my bed
what's worse lawyers are pounding in my
head mr. all and my good friend Drake's
text my phone Zeon's
[Music]
beautiful Kelly thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
dad's make it downward dog he buys a
poolside let her up with SPF 85 live
cold from the phone talking to you
laughs second fill in my body physical
it's a seaweed and sea Sun face mask
charcoal ginger up my ass hug someone
and make it last
don't you know that you burned it to
detox you're so big don't you know that
your birthday just everything will be
okay
take care Sunday
my father
[Music]
Hajis lotion on all of your own
I was asleep those
furnish with my besties to this end
right now
chance